there's been a lot of talk hasn't there
about areas where the UK is World
beating and some of it has frankly been
nonsense but let's have a look at an
area where certainly it is true when it
comes to vaccinations the UK has very
high levels of vaccines this is showing
the proportion of people who are double
jabbed just over the course of That
vaccine program so it's going higher and
higher and you can see let's just look
at that UK line it's higher than most
other countries around the world when it
comes to the proportion of people who
have got two vaccinations so that line
is very high but it does raise a
question doesn't it why are we seeing
cases Rising so high in the UK If we
take those same countries and look at
just cases per million of the population
well that's what you see a striking
increase in those numbers for the UK
cases going a lot higher than all those
other countries so why is that the UK
has so many people vaccinated and yet
you're seeing cases Rising particularly
well certainly among people who are
double Jabs so a lot of people who have
two vaccine vaccines still actually
getting covert 19. so does that mean
something's going wrong does that mean
the vaccines aren't working or as some
something else happening well for this
you need to remember that vaccines
broadly are aimed to do two things so
you've got first of all protecting you
from infection so protecting you
actually getting the disease secondly
protecting you from the consequences of
it so meaning it's not going to be as
severe you might not have to go to
hospital and those are two separate
things and there are different kind of
data points on how effective these
vaccines are on them this is latest data
from public health England it's talking
about the vaccines that are instituted
in the UK so we're talking about
AstraZeneca and physone looking at the
average here and the bars the higher
these bars are the more effective they
are against these different things so
we're going to look at against
Effectiveness against infection you can
see single jabbed 49 effective against
infection double jabbed 89 against uh
infection now this is for the alpha
variance so the first variant that you
that was in the UK around winter so
that's the Kent variant and you can see
you're up to 89 effective but if you
just look specifically at the Delta
variance so this new variant the Indian
variant some people call it that
Effectiveness again infection is lower
the bars aren't getting as close to that
hundred percent you're only up to 79
even if you're double jab so still a
significant chance of getting the
disease but then there's the second
thing so not just infection but severity
and where do those vaccines rate on that
axis well you can see here look this is
the same thing again the higher these
bars are the more effective the Jabs are
with each of these variants against
hospitalization and look with the single
jab you're up to 78 effective against
hospitalization 93 effective with two
Jazz but just look at Delta so in this
sense actually it's a bit better you can
see 96 effective against hospitalization
if I just kind of focus specifically on
those those bars so we're just looking
at Delta here just look you still have a
21 chance of being infected even if you
you are double jabbed whereas your
chance of being hospitalized is four
percent compared with those compared
with those who are unvaccinated so
that's pretty crucial you're talking
about two things still pretty porous
when it comes to cases and if we just
work this through a little bit more look
at the number of people who are
vaccinated around the UK and just think
about the fact that you know chunk of
these people might well get covert 19.
well fully vaccinated you've got 36
million or so just over 36 million those
were single dose 10.2 million then
you've got that proportion of
unvaccinated adults so this is
overrating so I'm vaccinated about 6.6
million and of course many of those
measures that the Prime Minister has
been talking about with checks on people
going into nightclubs that's potentially
to try and encourage those people mostly
younger people who are unvaccinated then
you've got under 18s as well but bear in
mind obviously we saw those numbers a
moment ago even if you're double jab
there's still a 21 chance of getting it
so that means about 7.6 million people
who could potentially get covert 19.
there's other things I should say going
on here there's question marks about how
resistant you are if you have antibodies
if you've caught the disease previously
and this this is a big simplification
but nonetheless I'm trying to underline
the fat there's still a lot of people
might well get covered even if they've
been double jabbed and then 65 chance of
getting the infection obviously if you
have a single dose of 65 of that is
about 6.6 million and add that all up
okay and you're talking about 14 million
just over 14 million potential
infections among people who have been
vaccinated and that's why we're likely
to see a lot of stories about people
who've been vaccinated who have actually
got the disease whereas you've got
unvaccinated that portion of the
population much lower final thing worth
mentioning is within this cohorts of
fully vaccinated people you're seeing
elderly people who are more vulnerable
to the disease who are potentially uh
more likely to die sadly of the of
covert 19. so that story is it's a
nuanced one but it's worth bearing in
mind because it's not just about
protecting you from actually getting the
disease it's also about protecting you
from hospitalization and when we see
that when you look at these lines
showing you case numbers that's case
numbers across the UK you can see
they're going up very sharply uh
potentially not as high as they are as
they were in the winter Peak but they
are pretty likely to get there frankly
and then you've got hospitalization so
it's on a different axis here but you
can see how correlated that redliners
with the dark blue line throughout
winter but just look at what's happened
more recently so cases going up very
sharply admissions certainly going up
but not as sharply as they did around
the time of the last wave and while they
are likely to go higher the question is
how much higher and the same obviously
goes for cases if we look around the UK
there are hot spots which give us Clues
as to where we might be heading so for
instance look we'll go here to the
Northeast you can see Redco and
Cleveland you've got
1563 cases per hundred thousand that's
the highest level in the UK so a real
hot spot around that Southeast area
there you can see Middlesbrough uh 14 uh
1 404 cases and the darker obviously
these these areas are the higher the
levels of covid-19 infections there if
we look around that Southeast area so
includes uh Middlesbrough wrecker as
well and just have a look at cases
versus hospitalizations so the same shot
I showed you a moment ago there you can
see cases look wow they are much higher
than they were in the winter the highest
I think they've ever been in this area
but now add on hospitalizations you can
see very correlated through the winter
but now they are going up they are
certainly going up look at how steep
that line is but whereas cases are
higher than they have ever been before
hospitalizations still considerably
lower than that peak in the winter so
that's encouraging and it underlines
that point we've just seen here that
there's two things going on there's the
spreading of the disease where the
vaccines aren't quite as effective but
then there's hospitalizations where they
are a lot more effective two different
things two different parts that we're
talking about with the vaccines find it
worth saying you know there is some
Regional variation around the UK if you
go up for instance the orkney islands
you're talking about 49 cases per 100
000 very low levels in Wales as well but
the expectation is that as we see
lockdown ending those numbers are going
to go higher and we're going to have to
keep monitoring all these charts